these are not good numbers and i will  defend  any day  that joe biden is the better choice than  donald trump and that joe biden has made  better decisions than donald trump but i  also can't lie to you and say that the  country is responding super positively  to joe biden his approval rating is  really low uh the average is now down to  37.4 that's an average of recent  approval polls for joe biden 57 percent  of americans now disapprove this is the  most disapproval and least approval of  joe biden  since he became president of the united  states compared to prior presidents you  have to go still all the way back to  truman in the 1940s to find a president  that on month  uh i guess it's month 18 of his  presidency had an approval this low you  compared to  even trump had a higher approval at this  point in time in his presidency barack  obama george w bush way way better than  biden at this point